nous accueillons notre invité du samedi
20 heures ce soir philippe croizon
bonsoir
or philippe le 5 mars 1994 z'avez 26 ans
votre vie va basculer pour toujours
électrocutés par une ligne à haute
tension
vous vous réveillez à l'hôpital amputé
des quatre membres
et là vous entrevoyez à la télé une
image qui restera à jamais scotché dans
votre mémoire une jeune fille de 17 ans
qui traversent la manche à la nage et
vous vous dites pourquoi pas moi un jour
voilà vous le ferez 32 km 100 brasse en
jambes et vous racontez votre exploit
dans un livre publié chez jean claude
gawsewitch et intitulé j'ai traversé la
manche à la nage on en parle à 20 heures
bonsoir vous êtes né le 20 mars 1968 à
châtellerault perdre au compteur mère
ouvrière chez aigle vos parents 18 ans
donc ils sont étranglés par
l'inexpérience et les difficultés
financières il vous confie ainsi que
votre grand frère à vos grands parents
et c'est auprès de votre grand-père que
vous prendrez le goût de l'armée
à l'école c'est pas terrible à vous est
dyslexique et à l'époque dyslexiques ça
veut dire bon à rien oui ça veut dire
qu'on s'occupe du poêle à fioul au fond
de la classe d'accord alors vos parents
vous pousse vers un apprentissage de la
charcuterie enfin c'est ça vous fait
parler quoi l'étudiante a dit non deux
ans et après je me sauve voilà donc vous
devancé l'appel pour le service
militaire et vous faites un service de
longue durée dans l'infanterie marine
à 17 ans vous avez rencontré muriel qui
avait 15 ans vous dites en la voyant je
suis subjugué quand même temps je suis
très jeune mais bon le coup de foudre et
puis voilà quoi donc
alors la séparation est insoutenable il
faut attendre 18 mois mais dix-huit mois
après c'est la quille et là vous trouver
un emploi stable aux fonderies du poitou
vous habitez une petite maison à saint
rémy sur creuse dans le nord du poitou
pas de salle de bain des wc dans la cour
l'humidité sur les murs on va vous êtes
jeune vous aimez brevet c'est la
première maison donc que tout va bien et
qu'elle mais quand muriel est à nouveau
en cinq là il faut trouver une autre
maison plus grande plus confortable et
le samedi 5 mars 1994 le jour du
déménagement donc tous vos amis sont là
pour vous aider à remplir le camion le
premier voyage se passe bien pause café
avant de repartir quand vous décidez de
monter sur le toit pour démonter
l'antenne de télévision vous dit pas
question de la laisser aux nouveaux
occupants
on est jeune voilà à l'antenne ça
coûtait cher j'avais fait venir à
l'installateur est tout et je dis bon je
vais le récupérer moi je prends une
échelle en aluminium ouais et je me
corps dans la cheminée j'attrape cette
antenne je commence à déboulonner quand
vous redescendez du toit avec l'antenne
dans les bras vous recevez soudain un
choc d'une puissance inouïe en fait il
ya un arc électrique qui s'est produit
dans une fois l'antenne une ligne à
haute tension qui est trop proche non
ces trois mètres la c1 mais 30 les
chaussures en caoutchouc donc tout va
bien je tiens ma je pose mes tibias et
la contact avec la terre ça me colle de
suie 20000 volts alors là au premier
choc vous voyez défiler toute votre vie
courte vie un moyen très courte vie 26
ans donc c'est très court alors là
soudain deuxième choc d'affilée charme
qui fait en fait effet d'électrochoc
c'est à dire que votre coeur redémarre
je redémarre mais je reviens là vivent
avec moins et à partir de ce moment là
je perds plus jamais connaissent en ce
moment là quand l'électricité est coupée
mais quand les agents de maintenance
réenclenche non courants en l'afsset
électrocuté pour la troisième fois et là
je reste sous tension voilà et cette
fois ci alors votre corps 30 sera
grandement à l'échelle se déforme et le
goudron de la route en bas fonds ouais
même la ligne téléphonique cette levée
de la chaleur passent par ligne
téléphonique et fait fondre le téléphone
quand la maison tellement la chaleur est
dantesque pain alors voilà vous vous
réveillez à l'hôpital
un
mois plus tard vous voulez vous lever
oui en pleine nuit ouais j'ai soif moi
j'ai une terrible soit fait derrière de
la torture et ultime et un robinet qui
fuit voilà qui de gouttes cluc club et
je dis bon aux siens je me levais jugé
sous évalué mais bon sang mais je vais
me lever à voilà melloul bord du 10 mai
et puis j'essaie de m'appuyer sur la
jambe mais je veux pas et la larme se
met en route et l'infirmière me rendors
accepted seringue magique pour que je
m'aperçois de rien là vous découvrez
l'horrible réalité alors vous voulez
mourir dans un premier temps on se
réveille on est on appuie bras on n'a
plus de jambes et on se pose la question
quel va être ma place au sein de la
société qu'elle est surtout ma place au
sein de ma famille est-ce que je vais
encore un père est ce que je vais te
recrute il a quelque chose il souffrait
le martyre car vous avez mal à vos
anciens membres ouais ça s'appelle la
douleur du membre fantôme journal mais
en ce moment on parle j'ai toujours mes
mains j'ai toujours mes doigts 1 je peux
jouer avec enfin voilà quoi mais c'est
une douleur qui est en permanence tout
le temps donc on fait plus attention et
un cerveau qui vous transmet toujours
cette voix là oui oui temps en temps il
envoie des décharges électriques pour
pour voir si les membres sont venus ou
quoi alors après il ya effectivement une
rééducation qui fait mal qui coûte cher
mais ça coûte très cher les prothèses
pour vos bras si 18000 euros
l'aménagement de la maison 13000 et la
voiture adaptée 31000 way mes parents
tout de suite et ils disent mais on peut
pas et on ne pourra jamais faire passez
donc ils ont réflexe de créer une
association est de dire voilà on va
créer des manifestations et tout on va
récolter des dons et grâce à eux je suis
une personne handicapée qui a énormément
de chance vraiment vraiment alors je
suis heureux parce que dès que besoin
d'un matériel taquet sont là ils
m'aident alors finalement vous revenez
chez vous alors au début vous avez
beaucoup de visites tout le monde vient
vous voir effectivement ça se passe
plutôt bien mais bientôt vous retrouvez
seul qui est normal et là c'est la
déprime et là je me me drague à la télé
oui je le reconnais vous devenez assez
que ces crabes avec muriel femaph hasbro
qu'on la fasse gros con c'est à dire que
tout est dû c'est moins handicapé donc
tout est dû c'est comme en centre de
rééducation ensemble de réduit quand on
est dans une bulle on est super protégés
on appuie sur une sonnette on vient vous
aider hélas dans ce coup on vous lâche
dans la nature vous essayez c'est fini
tu étais protestent et des machins aller
à la maison et là n'étaient pas préparés
alors le seul moment de bonheur de cette
époque c'est quand vous partez à la
ciotat avec handisport pour faire de la
plongée ouais ouais le retour à la vie
quoi alors on fait de la plongée c'est
très agréable mais le problème c'est que
quand vous revenez à la main ben c'est
d'autant plus difficile retrouvez dans
votre univers matinée tout seul parce
qu'elle travaille toute la journée
exactement
alors votre coupe se détériore à ce
moment là c'est pas facile pour muriel
d'être à la fois une épouse une
infirmière c'est extrêmement compliqué
elle sent bah ouais sept ans après là je
rentre dans une phase de colère
monstrueuse puisque j'avais décidé de
vivre pour mes deux garçons et que la
voilà le fait que mon époux ce sens là
et c'est une nouvelle douleur cette fois
ci pas physique simplement le coeur et
là j'ai bizarrement là je suis plus le
gars handicapés juste redevient normal
quoi et je n'accepte pas le fait de la
séparation ouais alors voilà le soir
même vous avez une bouteille de martini
dans une espèce de comas éthyliques vous
voulez vous jeter d'un pont il ya un
miracle c'est qu'au dernier moment votre
fils vous appelle vous lui répondez vous
entendez la voix de votre si c'est
évidemment vous ne vous jetez pas dans
la rivière non non il annonce que je
lâche des piges à jérémy où est ce que
je suis et moi je suis tellement péter
que ben voilà avec des prothèses déjà
tenir debout quand les bords mails avec
des prothèses sont encore pires donc
voilà je m'écroule et puis après ils me
retrouver alors il vous faudra trois ans
pour remonter la pente du désir dit vous
ai rencontré susanna qui emménagera chez
vous alors avec ses trois filles 2 chat
un chien
n'est pas du tout cela non non mais non
mais c'était énorme c'est trop complet
franchement c'est comme quoi tout est
jouable quoi j'avais super peur en
disant mais qui va être capable de
m'aimer pas de bras pas de gens quoi
c'est impossible cette histoire et puis
bah j'ai tenté ma chance sur internet
sur internet
et là il incroyable idée vous vient
votre staff un saut en parachute 5000 m
en chute libre mais à l'arrivée quand un
journaliste lui demande quel est votre
prochain défi vous répondais je vais
traverser la manche à la nage voilà et
là je demande à susanna si elle est
d'accord et puis même dit et c'est quoi
la traversée de la manche belge il n'en
sait pas plus que toi j'ai vu à la télé
il ya 14 ans aumônier d'hôpital un et on
rentre à la maison et on regarde sur
internet mon dieu 34km température de
l'eau 14° taux de réussite chez les
valides 10% mais dans quoi je me suis
embarquée est trop tard c'était parti
fallait y aller quoi alors vous trouvez
une entraîneuse s'appelle valérie
carbonel
incroyable bonne femme là vous commencez
à vous entraîner même si c'est inhumain
évidemment ouais bah oui mais premier 25
m g que j'allais mourir mais tu es
souffler le curve explorer avait dit je
pleurais de douleur mais j'ai retourné
le lendemain ouais c'est le jeu alors au
bout d'un an vous stagné un peu à trois
heures de nage par jour est la solution
consistera à changer les prothèses ouais
ouais les premières prothèses alors que
dadis côté walf le tfc 3 kg il a émis de
la mousse expansée c'était mon
prothésiste un cadeau au pied levé
rapidos et puis mais avant que les
ingénieurs travaille vraiment dessus et
ainsi de suite il a fallu est presque un
an en bout de deux ans vous nagez neuf
heures d'affilée ouais je rentre à 8
heures le matin dans la piscine sera
18h01 alors pour vous endurcir la coach
valérie vous concocte une épreuve
noirmoutier et pornic noirmoutier en
douze heures ouais aller retour nous
fêtons 10 heures ouais elle allait pas
qu'on tenterait pas d'y acheter demandé
12 heures je n'ai pas abordé l'histoire
tourne et vous avez refait deux heures
j'ai tourné en rond devant le port
je pouvais pas rentrer et le 18
septembre 2010 vous mettez à l'eau sur
la plage de folkestone dans le sud de
l'angleterre compliqué parce qu'au
départ il vous faut déjà presque deux
heures pour arriver à lorgues var
le tout le monde a peur on y met le
seuil c'est cuit quoi il va pas y
arriver c'est mort arrive au mieux la
traversée vous vomissez
de fatigue et de froid vous dites c'est
le fameux passage à vide oui j'ai trop
ralenti je le froid m'attaque j'ai les
coliques gemalodo j'ai mal au ventre
suis pas bien et là dans ma tête tout de
suite je dis non je dis c'est pas
possible quoi il ya plein de gens qui
t'ont fait confiance mongrain au début
tu es tout seul dans cette idée à la
noix et mais après y'a plus de 200
personnes qui tombent et derrière c'est
plus de 200 personnes derrière toi naj
et là je me mets à nager mais comme j'ai
jamais nagé de ma vie quoi j'étais en
pulsations à 130-140 tout le long là je
suis monté à 102 milles 180 pendant 20 à
25 minutes jacques d'un côté arnaud de
l'hôte et gueuler tous les deux à droite
à gauche en pleine nuit on voyait rien
et on fonce sans cap gris nez et lui si
qui lui a été super calme au début
c'était trop drôle ouais je suis dit si
je suis là pour constater et à la fin de
la traversée c'est lui le plus fort
alors là maintenant attendez il ya le
prochain défi ouais c'est réunir les
cinq continents à la nage alors d'abord
vous faites papouasie en indonésie pour
réunir le cni à la vie à l'asie ça fait
combien cela peut paraître peu près 20 à
25 bornes a quand même une treille
jordanie egypte l'appareil va à 25km
enseigne espagne maroc pour relier
l'afrique à l'europe c'est détroit de
gibraltar là ça se complique là ça
devient très dur ce que gibraltar s'est
vraiment l'atlantique qui remplit bassin
méditerranéen et là il ya des bacs dans
tous les sens un centre aux chocs et
tout il ya un contrat énorme donc là ça
va vraiment se corse et aaron un très
dur et la distance est plus courte en
revanche voilà on a quatorze kilomètres
à vol d'oiseau mais avec les courants le
vent va faire après 25 en pareil cas et
puis en alaska doux ici à la mairie non
mais c'est déjà bien les 3 t mobile
là on était très froide en entre 0 et 3
degrés et là on manage après six
kilomètres donc 2h 2h30 et là on s'est
vraiment entraîné à font romeu comme des
fous dans un lac qui venait de dégeler
on a nagé pendant quinze jours là haut à
font romeu je préparais en globules
rouges ainsi de suite et puis moi et
arnaud par exemple quand on prend un
bain ouais les glaces on l'aimé pas un
apéro non les maires la baignoire on
prend des bains avec des glaçons pas
vrai pour vraiment préparer le corps le
au froid y'a pas susan lendemain non là
non elle n'est pas d'accord
jusqu'ici l'exploit de relier les cinq
continents il ya qu un seul mec est
arrivé valide marque diaz way est là
mais moi je voulais pas le faire tout
seul je voulais faire avec un agent
valide un nageur valide un agents
handicapés tout les 2 reliant
symboliquement les cinq continents ça
veut dire qu'on n'est pas si loin les
uns les autres on se ressemble à tous il
est tous capable de faire la même chose
ya pas de différence
[Applaudissements]
bravo ça commence quand le 6 mai la
highway on vote le matin on va nager un
petit peu à 20h on a le résultat à 23h
et les politiques
merci de votre créature
les corrections de ne rien rater le in
auditive abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux